years ago the world came together to
sign the paris agreement
today we have to strengthen that global
unity
around ambitious new goals because this
will be the make or break decade for our
climate
and therefore i want to thank president
biden for convening this meeting on
earth day
the paris agreement is humanity's life
insurance
and at the cop 26 in glasgow we must
show
that we all have understood this and
that we are ready
for more climate action because we are
getting dangerously close to one and a
half degrees
of global warming science tells us
it's not too late yet but we must hurry
up
and that is what europe is doing 11 days
after taking office my commission
launched the european green deal
for transforming our economy and
yesterday
we agreed europe's first ever climate
law
with the european parliament and our 27
governments as angela merkel
mentioned with this rewrite into stone
the goal to set out set out by the
european green deal to make europe
climate neutral
by 2050 and we have also agreed to
reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by at least 55
percent
by 2030. in june my commission will
table
proposals to make europe fit for
55. we will make emission trading work
not only for energy generation and
industry
but also for transport and for buildings
carbon must have its price because
nature cannot pay the price any longer
but fit45 is not just about emissions we
will safeguard our nature and enhance
biodiversity
going for nature-based solutions
wherever possible
and we will ensure that all this is done
in a just
and inclusive way because for our
ambition to succeed
we must leave nobody behind
climate action is also a massive
opportunity for our economies it creates
new markets it mobilizes investment in
new and transforming industries
and it unleashes innovation for a
healthier and more prosperous future
and this is why thirty percent of
europe's
recovery plan next generation eu mario
draghi mentioned it
all together 1.8 trillion euro
is earmarked for climate related goals
the fight against climate change will be
the engine
for our global recovery and
it will be our compass for cooperation
with all of you
in many areas in research innovation
and breakthrough technologies through
forums like
mission innovation or in helping
vulnerable countries to become resilient
to climate change
europe wants to be the first climate
neutral continent in the world
but to save the climate we need the
world
we need all major economies to take
their responsibility
and to turn the transition into an
opportunity for all
let's set together a new global
benchmark for climate neutrality
let us work together on a shared
commitment
and joint action for reducing emissions
by 2030
this puts us on a pathway to net zero
emissions by 2050
and that is what our planet needs
thank you again president biden for this
meeting
it is so good to have the us back on our
side
in the fight against climate change
together we can go faster
and get further and together we will win
the future
thanks a lot
thank you very much madam president uh i
now turn the floor to his majesty king
[Music]
salman
you